Así es el presidente abrió de hecho su
conferencia con este tema antes de
abordar los asuntos que normalmente se
tocan en esta conferencia lamentó desde
luego los hechos como ya lo escuchábamos
dijo que fue alrededor de las nueve y
media de la noche Cuando ocurrió este
incendio que se produjo
reiteró López Obrador que al parecer
fueron los mismos migrantes quienes
iniciaron esta protesta al interior de
las instalaciones del Instituto Nacional
de Migración en la estación Lerdo esa
estación se encuentra a un lado del
puente internacional Lerdo que cruza
hacia ciudad de Ciudad Juárez a El Paso
Texas y bueno el mandatario refirió que
ya están en Ciudad Juárez
el director del Instituto Nacional de
Migración así como agentes de la
fiscalía general de la república para
llevar a cabo las investigaciones y
deslindar la responsabilidades confirmó
la de 39 muertos sabemos también que hay
29 heridos que han sido llevados a
cuatro hospitales de esta ciudad
fronteriza para recibir atención médica
qué otras cosas sabemos hasta el momento
bueno la información del Instituto
Nacional de Migración a través de un
comunicado Establece que ya hay
coordinación con las autoridades
consulares de distintos países para
aplicar lo que sea necesario para
identificar los cuerpos de estos
migrantes fallecidos algunos medios
locales Como por ejemplo el Diario de
Juárez que es destacado en noticias de
la frontera refiere que algunos de los
migrantes habían sido llevados a este
centro de detención luego de una redada
que hubo en los cruceros de esta ciudad
derivado de denuncias ciudadanas que
presentaron quejas esto Pues habría
puesto al albergue en condiciones de
presumiblemente de saturación por lo que
los migrantes en un acto quizá de
desesperación llevaron a cabo esta
protesta Lo cierto es que
no no se tiene aún identificados los
cuerpos y están ya las autoridades allá
hay desde luego indignación en la
sociedad tanto en Juárez como Pues en
todo el país por esta tragedia ocurrida
con los migrantes fueron varias horas
los que estuvieron laborando las
autoridades para pues recuperar los
cadáveres y llevarlos al servicio médico
forense en donde están Ya para su
identificación actualmente las
instalaciones del instituto de migración
están resguardadas por elementos de la
guardia nacional el ejército y también
peritos de la fiscalía general de la
república que llevan a cabo la
investigación para dar con los hechos
para dar como ocurrió esta tragedia que
pues insiste el presidente habría sido
provocada por los mismos migrantes al
parecer emprendiendo fuego a las
colchonetas de los dormitorios